From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
La Biblioteca del Congreso
recibe cada año cientos de
miles de preguntas de mentes
curiosas alrededor del mundo.
Los bibliotecarios de referencia
y especialistas de área de la
Biblioteca están listos y
esperando ayudarles con la
información que necesita.
Este video le mostrará la
manera más fácil de hacernos
una pregunta en línea
usando el servicio de
"Ask a Librarian" (Pregúntele
a un bibliotecario).
Este servicio gratuito está
disponible para cualquier
persona en cualquier
parte del mundo.
Comencemos en la página
principal de la biblioteca en
LOC.GOV Vaya a la esquina
superior izquierda y pulse las
tres barras horizontales.
Seleccione el enlace
"Ask a Librarian" (Pregúntele
a un bibliotecario) en el
menú desplegable.
Esta es la página
principal de Ask a Librarian.
Comencemos seleccionando el
formulario en línea (online
form) localizado en la parte
superior de la página.
Aquí estamos en el formulário
de Preguntas Generales a
"Ask a Librarian" Enviarnos
una pregunta es tan fácil como
escribirla en el
espacio indicado.
Por ejemplo: ¿Es cierto que
Susan B. Anthony era conocida
por su chal rojo?
No he logrado encontrar ninguna
información al respecto.
Complete el formulario
escribiendo su pregunta y otros
detalles adicionales
como por ejemplo,
que otros recursos
ha consultado.
Una vez que haya completado
todos los espacios requeridos,
indicados con un asterisco rojo,
pulse "Ask Your Question"
para terminar.
Aparecerá una página de
confirmación para indicar que
su pregunta fue enviada
con éxito.
También recibirá
una confirmación por
correo electrónico.
Una bibliotecaria le enviará
una respuesta completa en
aproximadamente 5 días
laborables o menos.
Si usted quiere consultar una
sala de lectura en específico,
puede escogerla de la lista
en la página principal de
"Ask a Librarian".
Por ejemplo, si usted tiene una
pregunta sobre fotografías de
la era de la guerra civil,
usted puede encaminar
su pregunta a Prints
and Photographs Division.
Si no está segura sobre que
enlace escoger, no se preocupe.
Siga adelante y seleccione
"online form" (formulario en
línea") localizado en la parte
superior de la página.
No importa el tema,
un bibliotecario encaminará
su pregunta a donde
necesita llegar.
Además del formulario de pedido
en línea de "Ask a Librarian,"
algunas áreas ofrecen
servicios de
"chat" durante horario limitado,
indicado con el ícono
de "chat."
Cualquiera que sea su pregunta,
nuestros bibliotecarios de
referencia están listos y
esperando para proveerles con
la información que necesita,
así que continúe
y ¡pregúntele a
un bibliotecario!
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as LOC.GOV,